jugendamt vor werbung der bundeskanzler
hat heute gesagt wie und never walk
alone und hat zum beispiel eine
dauerhafte heizkostenpauschale
versprochen ist damit ihre sorge vor
volksaufständen und eine spaltung der
gesellschaft besaitet wir tun alles als
bundesregierung dafür dass wir in dieser
nicht einfachen situation wo wir erleben
müssen dass der russische präsident eben
nicht nur mit waffen krieg führt sondern
auch energie als druckmittel einsetzt
dass wir als gesellschaft geschlossen
zusammenstehen weil das ist eines seiner
ziele gesellschaften demokratien zu
spalten und deswegen ist es ebenso
wichtig dass wir die soziale
unterstützung ist nicht einfach anlage
mitdenken und vor allen dingen auch
vorausschauend unterschiedliche
szenarien sind sie in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen und die falle von
wladimir putin getappt ich hatte so ein
bisschen das gefühl denn das waren ja
panik setzte eigentlich die sie gesagt
haben und andere gesagt haben und er
sieht doch jetzt eigentlich mensch
erwerber und andere in der regierung
deutschland sowieso habe ich total in
der hand sich komplett anders und wir
sind in keine falle getappt sondern wir
bereiten uns seit monaten bestmöglich
darauf vor dass auch energie von dem
russischen präsidenten als waffe
eingesetzt wird und auch mit blick auf
die formulierung die ich gewählt habe
ich hab mir bewusst gesagt zugespitztes
bezug sich jetzt nicht auch nur stream 1
sondern das bezog sich in der diskussion
darauf dass ich deutlich gemacht habe
hätten wir ganz zu beginn des krieges
als es forderungen gab mit einem
ölembargo mit einer sofortigen gasstopp
begeben sich die deutsche
bundesregierung gestellt hatte ich auch
persönlich in brüssel der
wirtschaftsminister der bundeskanzler
gesagt haben das geht nicht ich habe in
diesem gespräch deutlich gemacht warum
wir das damals gemacht haben wir damals
hätten wir dann von einem tag auf den
anderen jegliche fossile
gasimporte unterbinden müssen und dann
wäre mir vollkommen unvorbereitet
gewesen das sind wir jetzt nicht wir
haben in den letzten fünf monaten
spüren müssen dass alle möglichen tricks
methoden angewandt werden und deswegen
bereiten uns jetzt eben darauf was im
winter sein dennoch das ziel von
wladimir putin ist ja das narrativ zu
verändern kaum jemand spricht noch über
das leid in der ukraine auch dadurch
dass sie vor volksaufständen gewarnt
haben und andere davor waren wir müssen
energie sparen bedeutet weniger über das
leid in der ukraine gesprochen und mehr
über die angst stress im herbst oder
winter präsident an sorry aber noch mal
ich habe wie gesagt dass rückblickend
warum wir damals kein gas und öl embargo
gemacht haben aber sei es drum mit blick
auf die jetzige situation stimme ich
ihnen vollkommen zu wir erleben in den
letzten wochen zunehmend das über das
leid in der ukraine weniger berichtet
wird da sind auch auf ihren zeitungs
andere titelseiten als noch vor drei
monaten
und daher hatte ich auch schon vor
längerem gesagt wir müssen aufpassen
dass es nicht irgendwie zu seiner
gewohnheit wird tagtäglich sterben
menschen werden zivilisten angegriffen
wir haben ja gerade den bericht bekommt
von der osze noch mal deutlich gemacht
haben wie systematisch dieser russische
präsident jeden ganz bewusst zivilisten
angreifen gräueltaten passieren da war
das theater in mario pohl wo klar war da
sind vor allem familien vor allem kinder
drin trotzdem ganz bewusst bombardiert
streumunition mit eingesetzt bei
angriffen auf dem bahnhof und auch jetzt
nach wie vor die situation auch wenn sie
richtigerweise sagen dass nicht mehr so
viel in der öffentlichkeit davon ist
dass tagtäglich
unschuldige menschen sterben bleibe
putin macht sich über die energiepolitik
der bundesregierung bereits lustig er
hat gesagt vorschläge die bürger sollten
beim duschen mit warmem wasser sparen
sein zitat blödsinn solche politiker
sind für putin zu tat völlig verrückt
geworden damals meinte er offensichtlich
robert habeck also r freut sich über
diese die bahn dass ich freude was meint
ob er was weiß ich was macht es mehr ich
gesagt herzlich egal dieser russische
präsident führt an völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg gegenüber einem anderen
land der stadt oer alle methoden ein die
den direkte kriegsführung in der ukraine
er nutzt energie als waffe benutzt
getreide als waffe weil seinen versuch
eben ist unser land zu spalten die
europäische union zu spalten die
weltgemeinschaft die ja in ganz ganz
großer mehrheit diesen brutalen angriffs
krieg verurteilt zu spalten indem er
eben mit blick auf den krieg den er
ebenfalls für die spaltung herbeiführt
und das wichtige ist dass wir uns davon
weder erpressen noch treiben noch
sonstwas lassen sondern in dieser
schwierigen situation und einfach ist es
auf gar keinen fall in größtmöglicher
gemeinsamer verantwortung das tun was
die ukraine unterstützt und seien
zugleich das was unsere menschen in
unserem land schützt und auch weltweit
dafür sorgt dass die nöte der menschen
weltweit nicht noch heftiger werden
halten sie sich selbst an hab ich's
april wieder zu duschen sehen sie die
minuten
manchmal stehe ich zu spät auf dass ich
die sekunden zählen aber ich weiß das
klingt so nach kleinigkeiten aber wie es
in solchen situationen
ist viele kleine schritte bringen eine
auch
leider ist mein zeitplan vorher auch
schon so gewesen dass ich leider nicht
unendlich viel zeit habe man beim
duschen aber natürlich kann jeder darauf
achten wie man energie sparen kann wie
man vor allen dingen gar sparen kann wie
man strom sparen kann und deswegen finde
ich auch falsch dass jetzt ein bisschen
dargestellt wird was soll dieser
kleinkram wie gesagt auch aus kleinen
maßnahmen können wir in der summe
energie einsparen und so nachbarn in den
niederlanden haben dass zum beispiel
vorgemacht jedenfalls wenn ich das
richtig ist was mir berichtet wurde 20
prozent energieeinsparung wurde da
bereits gemacht wir sehen doch auch bei
den menschen im alltag jeder versucht
das bestmögliche zu tun kinder überlegen
in der schule die sie im beitrag leisten
können jetzt im sommer als der
spritpreis so hoch gegangen ist auch mit
dem neuen euro ticket hat das dazu
geführt dass in innenstädten der verkehr
um 20 prozent zurückgegangen ist das
heißt es gibt ja so ein spruch tausend
kleine menschen an tausend kleinen orten
dieser welt könnte sich der welt
verändern und darum geht dass millionen
menschen einstehen gegen diesen brutalen
angriffs krieg in der ukraine und zeigen
wir sind solidarisch und jeder leistet
seinen beitrag und ich glaube die
bevölkerung ist manchmal weiter als
vielleicht die die die politik dass sich
die politik an und sagen dass eben viel
getan werden kann
auch bei diesen energieproblemen was ich
dann logisch nicht verstehe ist warum
die grünen bei der atomkraft zur studie
sind der münchner stadtverband der
grünen hier in münchen hat sich gestern
dafür ausgesprochen das akw isar 2 für
einige monate über das jahresende hinaus
laufen zu lassen und sie haben auch
argumentiert dass dadurch eben kein
neuer atommüll entstehen was ist daran
falsch
in so schwierigen entscheidungsprozessen
es ist immer wichtig dass man fakten
grundlagen gegen schlips er geht ja sind
ja nicht ohne grund aus der atomkraft in
deutschland ausgestiegen jetzt sind wir
in einer notsituation wo wir uns alles
nochmal anschauen deswegen auch dort hat
robert habeck mit der umweltministerin
steffi lemke ja zusammen wer bereits
einen ersten test gemacht ob es helfen
würde mit blick auf atomkraftwerke wir
sind zu dem schluss damals gekommen
gerade mit strom atomkraftwerke
produzieren ja strom und wir haben vor
allen dingen die herausforderung mit der
versorgungssicherheit bei gas das
brauchen wir in dem bereich zusätzliche
unterstützung atomkraft macht 56 prozent
überhaupt ein kleiner teil sprechen
kleinemas wahnsinn fünf bis sechs
prozent stromversorgung aus wir reden
über den standort bayern das heißt das
kraftwerk macht weniger aus und all das
steckt jetzt robert habeck aber ich
möchte an dieser stelle also ich meine
wir sind ja nicht in einer situation wo
alles friede freude eierkuchen ist
sondern auch in so einer schwierigen
situation da gibt es massive interessen
und natürlich gibt es einige im land die
schon immer gesagt haben sollten
atomkraft der einstein ich möchte mit
meinem team von bernburg der sein licht
nicht dass man das tut was notwendig und
richtig ist und nicht das wo man denkt
das ist ein placebo am ende winkt das
einfach gar nicht lassen sie mich jemand
hinter der sehr glaubwürdiges rebecca
harms wird zu den grünen der ersten
stunde und hat damals im wendland den
widerstand gegen atomkraft organisiert
und heute sagt sie es darf in der
diskussion zitat keine heiligen kühe
geben und die drei deutschen
atomkraftwerke sollen ende des jahres
nicht abgeschaltet werden sehen sie das
völlig anders ja dass ich
das und wir haben ja auch mit blick auf
die drei atomkraftwerke ohnehin die
betreiber die das betreiben haben wir
etliche schon erklärt dass das nicht
funktioniert aber das ist nicht mein
mein haupt themenfeld das anschließende
dass der aussicht auf die drei
atommeiler länger am netz bleiben
deswegen überprüft robert habeck er in
einem zweiten stresstest genau noch mal
die situation und die ergebnisse
die warten wir aber ich möchte noch mal
deutlich machen also schlicht in einer
gaskrise hören wird so ich finde es
nicht für den richtigen schritt auf der
faktenlage die ich gerade kenne und mit
blick auf das was unsere herausforderung
ist unsere herausforderung gas deswegen
ist atomkraft nicht die antwort auf eine
gasversorgung und zugleich ist es ebenso
wie gesagt dass wir nicht beschlüsse
dieses land gemeinsam beschlossen hat
einfach so zurücknehmen auch bei der
frage kohlereserven ist ja ganz klar
dass wir gesagt haben es ist erstmal
eine reserve für den strombereich und
diesen schritt sind wir als
bundesregierung gemeinsam und
geschlossen gang gesehen nicht dass
atomkraft hier die antwort ist aber ist
auf ich hab dazu jetzt alles gesagt
möchte waren fotos sprechen von dieser
woche da sehen wir auf einem bild bleibt
mir putin wir sehen hanni und wir sehen
erdogan hand in hand
wenn sie so ein bild sehen spüren sie da
räkeln
weiß nicht ob gefühle der beste maßstab
für nationale politische entscheidungen
sind das deutlich macht ist wie wichtig
derjenigen ist die gemeinsam wie wir an
die internationalen regeln nicht nur
glauben sondern für sie eintreten dass
wir mit werte partnern zusammen stehen
weil es gibt andere akteure die nicht
für unsere werte einstehen und die
verbünden sich im zweifel auch dass der
türkische präsident mit auf diesem foto
ist das ist eine herausforderung um es
mal freundlich zu sagen weil die türkei
ja gerade mit blick auf die ukraine das
sind dadurch eine massive unterstützung
im militärischen bereich leistet auch
jetzt mit blick auf die getreide
lieferung und deswegen ist mir dieses
foto mehr als unverständlich geradeaus
sicht eines nato mitglieds sie haben zu
beginn das ukraine krieges gesagt dass
die sanktionen gegen russland die
wirtschaft ruinieren bleibt es sich bei
diesem satz glauben sie immer noch dass
die sanktionen wie sie jetzt sind die
russische wirtschaft ruinieren wird auf
mittel und langfristige sicht ist der
ganze krieg den der russische präsident
führt auch gegen sein eigenes volk
gerichtet weil in einer situation wo die
kriegsführung über allem und jedem steht
auch seine eigene wirtschaft seine
eigene bevölkerung zu opfern und die
sanktionen werden ja nur eine reaktion
sind auf diesen diesen russischen krieg
führen dazu bei dass die
wirtschaftskraft von russland natürlich
massiv eingeschränkt wird also die
verantwortung für die ruine des
russischen landes der russischen
volkswirtschaft die trägt der russische
präsiden aber in den portalen angriffs
aber gar nicht putin argumentiert ja
dass die sanktionen im weniger treffen
als uns und es gibt ja auch immer mehr
in deutschland die das versuchen zu
argumentieren und sagen die sanktionen
die garde sind die treffen uns mehr als
musste
kurzfristig ist das sicherlich so dass
wir große herausforderungen haben aber
wenn man sich anschaut was in
deutschland los ist muss man sich halt
vergegenwärtigen das ist ja kein
normales system das ist eine autokratie
und das ist keine demokratie in jedem
normalen land was auf demokratischen
füßen steht müssen natürlich jeder
präsident der jeder bundeskanzler
ministerpräsident sofort zurücktreten
wenn die spitze des landes das land wäre
es wenn wir inflationsraten haben denn
große teile von internationalen
konzernen nicht mehr agieren würde ich
meinen dass alles reale auswirkungen in
russland die treffen natürlich russland
1000 mal mehr als das was wir eine
herausforderung wirtschaftlich haben wir
haben doch nicht die zahlen hier bei uns
in deutschland wie in russland die sache
ist nur die in russland ist es so dass
jeder der das zur sprache bringt
entweder im gefängnis landet oder das
land verlassen muss weil keine kritische
stimme mehr hörbar ist und deswegen ist
die situation so dass die reaktion des
landes eine andere ist weniger hart als
sie es wäre wenn all die auswirkungen
bei uns sichtbar werden lassen uns über
die situation an der front in der
ukraine sprechen ich glaub ich noch
einen satz zu sagen weil der mir wichtig
ist weil viele zu recht auch auf meiner
tour durch deutschland mache fragen ja
aber die sanktionen verhindern ja den
krieg gar nicht das stimmt und die
sanktionen waren auch nie so dass wir
uns überlegt haben wenn wir russische
energieimporte reduzieren das dann
morgen der krieg vorbei ist deshalb
gleich zu beginn der sanktionen auch
immer wieder versucht gegenüber der
ukrainischen regierung deutlich zu
machen dieses wenn nur noch 10 2 nicht
kommt wenn nur öl embargo endlich kommt
dann ist der krieg vorbei weil es
vollkommen klar war ein präsident der
sein eigenes land bereit ist zu opfern
der wird sich auch von
wirtschaftssanktionen nicht abbringen
lassen aber und das mir wichtig wir
verteidigen hier die internationale
regeln und der internationale ordnung
und wenn wir dann sagen wir greifen zu
recht nicht militärisch ein aber wir es
hat auch keinen ökonomischen folgen
würden wir das akzeptieren dass wir in
etwa so wenn wir in deutschland stets 15
jahre auf mord das verhindert nicht dass
nicht auch ein mord passiert und niemand
in deutschland würde auf die idee kommen
zu sagen an diese strafe bringt es jetzt
ja nicht wir schaffen weil die strafen
ab sondern es ist ein signal an die
gesellschaft wir akzeptieren diesen
massivsten regelbruch nicht so wie wir
als internationale gesellschaft als
internationale ordnung sagt wir
akzeptieren nicht wenn ein land und dann
noch ein land was ständiges mitglied im
sicherheitsrat ist die die regeln der
vereinten nationen so brutal bericht das
sind sogar die situation einer front
besprechen
seit knapp zwei wochen zurück ein
offizier dort sagte mir dann war es das
was zu uns geliefert wird ist zum gewinn
des krieges zu wenig und zum sterben zu
viel
warum entscheidet sich die regierung
nicht klar
die deutsche regierung aber auch andere
dass die ukraine gewinnen müssen und das
habe ich ja schon klar und deutlich
formuliert dass die menschen in der
ukraine ein recht darauf haben in
frieden und freiheit und sicherheit zu
leben und dass frieden und freiheit nur
zu gewährleisten ist wenn die
landesteile wenn man uns das anschauen
da wo jetzt russische truppen stehen
dass die ukrainisch wieder sind auch die
krim ist gewinnen für sie also wenn sie
sagen die ukraine musste krieg gewinnen
bedeutet dass mit der krim mit dem
gesamten ost die die krim ist
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert deswegen
gibt es seit 2014 sanktionen aufgrund
dieser völkerrechtswidrige besetzung der
krim welche schritte wann wie wo gehen
das ist aber das ist die definition der
gewinn für sie wenn sie sagen können
musste krieg gewinnen werden wenn die
ukrainische regierung souverän über ihr
staatsgebiet entscheiden kann und was
dann da vivo dazu gehört das liegt ganz
allein in den händen der ukrainisch
demokratisch gewählten regierung und
nicht in den händen irgend einer
ausländischen regierung und deswegen
sagen wir klar so undeutlich wir
unterstützen die ukraine dass die
menschen dort in frieden aber auch in
freiheit leben können all diejenigen
jetzt auch sagen ja gut aber wenn keine
bomben fallen dann ist das aus meiner
sicht nicht automatisch frieden und
freiheit die abwesenheit von krieg
bedeutet eben nicht dass man automatisch
frei leben kann dann muss man nur einmal
aber was bedeuten ihre worte zu gelangen
janowski ja fragen aber was soll das da
fallen keine bomben und trotzdem ist
gelangt nicht frei und und das ist so
wichtig wenn wir jetzt darüber reden
warum wir auch in der situation
militärisch die ukraine weiter
unterstützen selbst in der zeit
offensichtlich die die russen
militärisch stärker auftreten
sie halten starke reden und sie sind da
in der diskussion auch ganz klar und
auch mit ihren worten aber wenn wir uns
die situation so anschauen ist es das
seit wochen keine deutschen waffen mehr
dorthin gelangt sind
warum zwingt sie den kanzler nicht dazu
mehr waffen zu liefern oder warum sagen
sie nicht gut wenn das nicht passiert
pillen gegeben
sollten die letzten halbsatz oft werden
überspitzt formuliert war wie ich
vielleicht auch gerade überspitzt
formuliert habe in der derzeitigen
situation wenn es industriell stärkste
land in europa sagt wir haben neuwahlen
ich glaube größeren gefallen könnte man
dem russischen präsidenten überhaupt
nicht mehr druck da so mehr warten
darauf einmal das einmal denkt seit
wochen keine waffen wir angekommen sind
da stimmt ja nicht also mit die frage
seit wochen die panzerhaubitzen die wehr
geliefert haben und ein weiterer liefern
die sind in den letzten wochen
angekommen werden sie es nochmal erhöht
wir haben mit blick auf die die weiteren
lieferungen gerade auch mit blick auf
flugabwehr auch bewegt auf drohnen in
den letzten wochen immer wieder material
wenig handarbeit vom ein großes aber das
ist nicht perfekt das ist vollkommen
klar wenn die ukraine militärisch
überlegen wäre dann hätten wir andere
situation es ist aber eben auch nicht so
einfach wie man sich das vorstellt wir
haben seit jahrzehnten die bestände der
bundeswehr massiv reduziert wir haben
jetzt mit dem panzerhaubitzen erstmalig
aus beständen der bundeswehr geliefert
ich hatte schon in der vergangenheit
gesagt ich finde wir müssen uns
anschauen was in beständen möglich ist
und zugleich haben die verpflichtung
innerhalb der nato ich kann jetzt nicht
sagen wir geben alles also wir haben
einfach nicht mehr sagen das habe ich
nicht gesagt ich habe gesagt wir schauen
uns ganz genau was können wir abgeben
machen sie nicht mehr druck oder im
hintergrund warten sie vor dem
hintergrund dass wir zugleich zurecht
dem baltikum versprochen haben wenn ihr
angegriffen werdet dann wären wir gar
das heißt all das müssen wir in balance
bringen plus mit berücksichtigen dass
wir sehr viele teile haben das habe ich
in den letzten monaten sollen wir alle
lernen müssen sie haben zwar in den
beständen dann faktisch irgendwelche
zahlen an panzer oder an zahlen von von
auch artillerie
funktionsfähig ist aber nur ein teil
davon so wie reflektieren in der
bundesregierung gemeinsam wenn mehr tun
können auch mit blick auf den ringtausch
wo wir sehen das ist offensichtlich
nicht so funktioniert wie das geplant
war zu schauen damit dann auch wirklich
das material ankommt was ist da los dann
tauchen also wir hören zitat aus dem
spiegel der polnischen vize
außenminister zitat die deutschen
versprechen zum panzer ringtausch haben
sich als täuschungsmanöver ergebnissen
ist eine art vorbild ja und in so einer
situation täuscht man seinen
europäischen nachbarn ich habe die
gespräche ja auch geführt das macht
jetzt die zuständige
verteidigungsministerium weiter von
anfang an war klar dass wir natürlich
nicht von heute auf morgen mit dem
finger schnippt jeden einzelnen panzer
ersetzen können keine neuen panzer die
haben wir ja selber gar nicht sondern
die müssen ja überhaupt dort seien aber
offensichtlich ist gerade mit blick auf
polen die situation so dass wir nicht
schon erlösung kommen die für alle
unbefriedigend ist also das macht mir
auch spaß ist jetzt auch hier das
falsche wort ja dass das geht einerseits
natürlich allen an die nieren hier hat
dem 1 sag ich unter anderem auch wenn
wir uns jetzt darüber streiten dass die
einen sagen zu viel war zu wenig was
können wir liefern warum wie verkehr
nicht erst mal die ihr habt auch das ist
ja eine frage die man sich stellen muss
also natürlich können sie sagen wir
wollen mehr von euch haben aber trotzdem
können die panzer die sie haben auch
direkt in die ukraine ich möchte noch
einmal verstehen weil sie ja wirklich
mit ihren worten sowohl im bundestag in
interviews immer sehr klar sind sie
sagen wir müssen ihn unterstützen in
calais muss gewinnen und gleichzeitig
passieren diese dinge das verstehe ich
nicht die polen sind sauer auf
deutschland in kaliner sind immer noch
sauer alle sagen das kommt nicht genug
haben sie persönlich genug dafür getan
aus ihrer sicht den kanzler davon zu
überzeugen dass mehr geliefert wird
mit absolutes man habe ich eh nicht so
würde man aufhören sich ständig zu
verbessern deswegen jeden tag schauen
wir dass wir besser werden können und
auch besser werden können in der
unterschiedlich versteht total ihren
punkt und nichtsdestotrotz ist es so
dass wir auch mit blick auf ihre auf die
nachbarländer immer schauen müssen was
können wir leisten wir sind in sondern
will heuer leisten
das ist natürlich auf kosten anderer
stellen das hat ja gerade gesagt werden
sie dafür mehr schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu bringen jetzt in den nächsten
wochen ich habe mehrfach deutlich
gemacht dass wir gerade bei der hat der
larry schauen müssen wie wir das
verstärkt unterstützen können
eine letzte frage
damit ist sie da verstehe warum liefern
wir denn nicht eigentlich leo zwei
marder fuchs panzer warum sagen wir
nicht wir tun jetzt alles damit sie ja
sagen die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt
warum tun wir nicht mehr im blick dass
ich das dann olaf scholz und warum
handeln wie so liegt das daran dass wir
tatsächlich angst haben vor einem
atomschlag dass wir angst haben von
wladimir putin mehr oder weniger direkt
angegriffen werden
also bei den konkreten fragen sie jetzt
gestellt hat da liegt es nicht daran
natürlich müssen wir immer reflektieren
das bedeutet so handeln deswegen haben
wir zum beispiel zu beginn des krieges
als gefordert wurden ist flugverbotszone
einzurichten wo der erste reflex ja auch
sein könnte das muss man auf jeden fall
tun als man damals die bombardierung
gesehen hat wie viele menschen ums leben
gekommen sind haben dann entschieden
dass wir das nicht tun können weil wir
dann militärisch in diesen krieg hätten
eingreifen das land selber mit
flugzeugen in die ukraine hätten fliegen
müssen deswegen haben wir uns an dem
punkt für einen anderen schritt
entschieden und das gleiche gilt sich
machen großen sprung weil wir immer vor
der eigenen verantwortung
ja diese entscheidung treffen auch für
die menschen in unserem land in unserem
gemeinsamen europa haben mit blick auf
den panzerlieferungen
deutlich gemacht und auch mit blick auf
den ringtausch wo ich in
brüssel beim nato-treffen ganz stark
dafür geworben hatte weil es in der
situation so schien dass es am
schnellsten geht wenn wir alte
sowjetische panzer liefern können wir
sofort bedient werden können wenn sich
herausstellt dass das nicht funktioniert
aber wie gesagt das liegt nicht allein
an uns weil die panzer könnten ja sofort
geliefert werden dann müssen sie ja uns
jetzt gemeinsam anschauen und das tun
wir in der bundesregierung warum das
offensichtlich nicht passiert und ob wir
dann andere unterstützung leisten müssen
aber diese rhetorische frage die haben
wir ja auf den weg gebracht weil es uns
zu dem zeitpunkt das beste und
schnellste mittel schieben wenn dieser
weg nicht richtig war und ich weiß nicht
wer in kriegssituationen immer sofort
weiß das ist der perfekt richtige weg
dann müssen wir das natürlich
reflektieren und schauen wie wir dann
arbeite ich aktiv werden können sie
persönlich sorge dass wladimir putin
eine atombombe einsetzen könnte in den
nächsten monaten in den nächsten jahren
in diesen ich glaube dass wir in der
situation sind das hat ja auch
mehrfaches nachfragen zu meiner
begriffswahl wo ich gesagt habe ich
formuliere das mal bewusst überspitzt
das schlägt sofort ein als wenn man
dinge absolut stellt deswegen halte ich
überhaupt nichts davon zu spekulieren zu
spekulieren gerade in bereichen die
natürlich viele menschen
besorgniserregend sind wir überprüfen
ständig mit unseren eigenen
sicherheitsdiensten mit den
sicherheitsdiensten
nachrichtendiensten von unserer
befreundeten partnern wie die situation
ist wir haben deutlich gemacht aufsehen
gesorgt ich habe nicht die sorge dass
ein mittel gewählt wird was dazu führen
würde dass mit blick auf die globale
situation
die welt komplett eine andere wäre weil
ist es ja so dass der russische
präsident da sieht man ja auch an seinen
äußerungen schon sehr genau beobachtet
wie ist die globale resonanz deswegen
mehr als außenministerin auch so wichtig
ist weltweit zu erklären was wir hier
tun als der vorwurf war wir würden es da
hin wenn das getreide aus russland
rauskommt war ich überall unterwegs hat
sagt das stimmt nicht es gibt keine
sanktionen auf lebensmittel und so ist
es auch hier in diesem bereich es ist
vollkommen klar für den russischen
präsidenten das im nuklearbereich wohin
klar machen geächtet sind es gibt nur
sehr starken die sie natürlich haben
aber vollkommen klar ist dass das die
welt so ein schritt nicht akzeptieren
würde das auch ein russischer präsident
genau weiß dass solche sachen solche
waffen nicht zum einsatz aller letzter
tage mit schnellem der betrüger
schnellen antwort viele menschen fragen
sich wann ist dieser krieg zu ende und
wie kann das leiden gestoppt werden wie
lange bitten
ich wünschte ich wüsste das wäre dann
hätte ich auch den schlüssel in hand
diesen krieg zu beenden und wenn ich
diese kräfte hätte dann wäre der krieg
er gestern vorbei gewesen aber die
brutale realität ist dass diesen
schlüssel derzeit der russische
präsident allein in der hand hält wenn
der krieg vorbei sein sollte das leiden
das bomben dann könnte putin diesen
krieg morgen stoppen er will es nicht
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
die ukraine weiterhin auch wenn sie
fragen stellen warum geht's einstelle
weiterhin unterstützen dass sie sich
verteidigen können jahrelang geprägt das
weiß ich nicht wir tun alles dafür dass
der krieg zu ende geht deswegen helfen
der kanzler deswegen ist der
generalsekretär unterwegs deswegen sind
wir immer wieder dabei mit dem inland zu
sprechen mit den chinesen zu sprechen
mit denjenigen zu sprechen die von sich
behaupten ihre sogenannte neutralität
würde dazu beitragen dass der krieg zu
ende geht aber das ist eben das weswegen
es auch so wichtig ist dass wir gewonnen
haben wir nicht schweigen
weil wenn wir dieses verhalten
akzeptieren würden wir andere länder
einladen das gleiche zu tun und das
können wir nicht verantworten und da wo
wir verantwortung jetzt derzeit in der
realpolitik übertragen können tun würden
hast das sind die waffenlieferung das
sind auch humanitäre lieferungen das ist
die aufnahme von geflüchteten das ist
die versorgung mit getreide in der welt
und die geschlossenheit die wir haben
wenn ich diese minute noch habe möchte
ich das einmal sagen ich erlebe ein land
ich erlebe eine europäische union so
viele gefragt haben wozu brauchen wir
europa was soll das bitte sein das
friedensprojekt europa jetzt spüren wir
alle dass der größte segen auf uns ist
in einer gemeinsamen europäischen union
zu leben und diese beieinander zu halten
dass sich auch als die zentrale
ausfuhren deutscher schon außen als
chance und sorgte so zu müssen beendet
werden also gewusst hätten gemeinsam
das ende des satzes was ich gerade
gesagt habe deswegen ist eine zentrale
aufgabe eine deutschen außenministerin
in dieser situation alles dafür zu tun
dass die europäische geschlossenheit
beieinander bleibt und wir eben deutlich
machen auch gegen unseren ungarischen
nachbarn dass wir in dieser situation
beieinander stehen müssen solidarisch
bei der energieversorgung europaweit und
auch bei dem durchhalten von sanktionen
und das weiß auch ungarn das weiß der
westliche balkan wenn wir da jetzt
irgendwie drücken unser arid was mir
spaß muss moldau denken was müssen all
die anderen länder denken die auch sorge
haben dass russland sie angreifen könnte
mit diesen worten herzlichen dank frau
berg und wir
hoffen dass dieser krieg schneller zu
ende gehen als wir alles denn erst dann
geben